der bundesminister was ist das besondere
an der auszeichnung von tänzern des
jahres prozent
ich möchte damit zum ausdruck bringen
dass gerade auch beim tanzsport viel
einsatz viel engagement viel
beharrlichkeit dabei ist und daher auch
der tanz sport eine wichtige sportart
eine wichtige leistung sportart ist und
das möchten wir ausdrücklich würdigen
die militär anerkennungs medaille ist
natürlich etwas ganz ganz besonderes und
vor allem da wir sie vom minister
persönlich bekommen haben hat uns
natürlich extrem gefreut
ich hoffe dass meine eine gute
ergebnisse nicht gemacht habe bei den
österreichischen dancing stars werden
weiter folgen in deutschland und auch
vielleicht wenn nicht bei mir vielleicht
wird die card werden auch gute chancen
haben
und ja ich glaube dass ich hoffe dass
deutschland wird uns genauso gut
empfangen wie wir das gewohnt sind auch
in österreich
ich wünsche der frau korporal und dem
herrn korporal viel energie viel kraft
viel glück aber auch viele schöne
erlebnisse